deux ans de travail récompensé avec une
création originale
révélé l'an dernier à la cathédrale de
strasbourg
un vitrail où son visage derrière cette
oeuvre d'art pierre-alain parrot c'est
dans son atelier que le vitrail a pris
forme
mois après mois un projet inédit réalisé
avec une plasticienne photographe
intéressant c'était d'essayer de
remporter ce challenge de reproduire sur
verre des photographies avec nos
techniques pérennes du vitrail c'est à
dire des émaux qui sont des couleurs
vitry fiable qui sont intégrées dans le
vert à haute température et qui donne à
décor complètement indélébile et qui
franchira les siècles oeuvres mouvantes
le vitrail est indissociable de la
lumière qui le traversent
alors pour créer il faut une large
palette de couleurs aux nuances révélée
par le soleil car travailler le verre
c'est avant tout travailler avec la
lumière en vitrail sont les miens ne vit
pas et les noirs on voit très bien donc
révélateur de la couleur dans le vert
c'est le seul soleil la lumière
naturelle qui grâce aux oxydes
métalliques qui sont dans le vert ont
filtré cette lumière naturelle laisser
passer des rayonnements rouge bleu ou
jaune vert en plus des créations
pierre-alain part au restaurent c'est
d'ailleurs son activité principale
un travail long minutieux comme sur ce
vitrail de la cathédrale de bayonne du
15e siècle une pièce creusé par l'eau
principal ennemi du verre le décès
vraiment de supprimer les produits
l'altération qui risque de maintenir
dit et surface des verts et de modifier
le problème de péage qui sont la surface
des verts en plus ces vitraux seront
protégés par une double verrière donc
ils ne seront plus soumis à l'agression
physique et chimique du temps pour aider
le maître verrier une douzaine de
petites mains chargées de recomposer ces
pièces de puzzle très particulière c'est
la remise en plomb elle consiste à
remplacer les anciens plomb avant de les
souder toutes les étapes en vitrail
prennent du temps
c'est quand même des oeuvres d'art
fragile c'est des vitraux qui ont été
créés en dix noeuds 15 150 voyez c'est
des vitraux quand même qui en cinq
siècles et qui nécessitent vraiment un
soin très attentif la france est le pays
qui possède le plus gros patrimoines de
vitraux dans le monde depuis près de 70
ans l'atelier familial participe à sa
conservation